en este vídeo voy a hacer varios
ejemplos relacionados con las
propiedades de los exponentes pero antes
de que hagamos eso revisemos brevemente
lo que significa un exponente impar
supongamos que tenemos 2 elevado a la
tercera potencia tú puedes estar tentado
a decir bueno eso es 6 yo te diré no eso
no es 6 esto quiere decir 2 multiplicado
por sí mismo
3 veces es decir esto es igual a 2 por 2
por 2 lo cual es igual a 2 por 2 4 por 2
8 esto es igual a 8 si te pregunto a
cuánto es igual 3 a la segunda potencia
o 3 al cuadrado esto es igual a 3
multiplicado por sí mismo dos veces esto
es igual a 3 por 3 lo cual es igual a 9
hagamos un último de estos creo que ya
estás agarrando la idea si es que nunca
habías visto estos supongamos que
tenemos 5
5 elevado a la digamos séptima potencia
esto es igual a 5 multiplicado por sí
mismo
7 veces es 5 por 5 por 5 por 5 por 5 por
5 por cinco veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 5 a la
séptima este va a ser un número muy muy
muy grande no lo voy a calcular aquí
pero tú lo puedes ser a mano o con una
calculadora para checar qué es un número
enorme una de las cosas que es fácil
darse cuenta es que los exponentes
incrementan los números rápidamente ya
puedes imaginarte entonces que 5 elevado
a la potencia 17 es un numero
escandalosamente grande en fin esta es
una pequeña revisión de exponentes y
ahora entremos al álgebra utilizando
exponentes ahora
cuánto es 3 déjame ponerlo con otro
color cuánto es 3x por 3 x por 3 x cuál
es el resultado de esa multiplicación
una de las cosas que tienes que recordar
de la multiplicación es que no importa
el orden en el que hacen las
multiplicaciones así es que esto es
igual a 3 por 3 por 3 por x por equis y
por equis ahora por lo que vimos acá
arriba 3 por 3 por 3 esto de aquí 3 x sí
mismo 3 veces es 3 al cubo y lo mismo
pasa para este término x multiplicado
por sí mismo 3 veces es x al cubo así es
que esto puede ser escrito como 3 al
cubo por x al cubo o como sabemos 3
elevado a la tercera potencia es 9 por 3
lo cual nos da 27
así es que esto es igual a 27 x cúbica
aquí podrías decir oye no era esto 3x x
3 x x 3 x es decir 3 x al cubo a poco no
estamos multiplicando 3x por sí mismo 3
veces
y te diré tiene razón esto de aquí lo
puedes interpretar como 3x elevado a la
tercera potencia y así hemos llegado a
una de las propiedades de los exponentes
cuando tienes algo multiplicado por algo
y todo eso elevado al cubo a la tercera
potencia esto es igual que elevar cada
uno de esos términos al cubo y luego
multiplicar aquí tenemos 3 al cubo por x
al cubo lo cual es igual a 27 x cúbica
hagamos algunos ejemplos más qué tal si
te pregunto cuánto es
pongamos 6 al cubo
6 a la sexta y este va a ser un número
realmente grande pero lo quiere escribir
como potencias de 6 déjame escribir 6 a
la sexta con un color diferente entonces
6 al cubo por 6 a la sexta a cuánto va a
ser igual bueno 6 al cubo 6 al cubo
sabemos que es 6 por sí mismo 3 veces 6
por 6 por 6 y eso multiplicado por deja
de poner el signo de por aquí en verde
no mejor voy a usar el naranja wüst el
naranja mejor entonces eso multiplicado
por 6 a la sexta potencia 6 a la sexta
potencia que es 6 x sí mismo 6 veces
esto es 6 por 6 por 6 por 6 por 6 a ivan
5 una más por 6 y este número cuánto va
a ser bueno estamos multiplicando 6 por
sí mismo cuántas veces estamos
multiplicando 123456789 veces correcto
tres veces aquí
y seis veces aquí estamos multiplicando
seis por sí mismo nueve veces esto es
igual entonces a seis elevado a la tres
más seis lo cual es igual a seis a la
novena potencia y de esta manera hemos
arribado nuevamente a otra propiedad de
los exponentes cuando tenemos exponentes
en este caso 6 al cubo el número 6 es la
base la cual estamos elevando al
exponente 3 cuando tienes la misma base
y estás multiplicando dos exponentes que
tienen la misma base puedes sumar los
exponentes así si yo tengo déjame hacer
algunos ejemplos más sobre esto y
hagámoslo ahora en magenta supongamos
que tenemos 2 al cuadrado por 2 a la
cuarta
por dos a la sexta potencia tengo la
misma base así es que puedo sumar los
exponentes esto es igual a 2 elevado a
la 24 más 6 y esto es igual a 2 elevado
a la potencia 12 y espero que esto te
haga sentido aquí tenemos 2 al cuadrado
2 por sí mismo dos veces aquí
multiplicamos dos por sí mismo cuatro
veces y aquí multiplicamos dos por sí
mismo seis veces en total están
multiplicando dos por sí mismo 12 veces
o 2 elevado a la potencia 12 hagamos un
ejemplo más abstracto usando algunas
variables pero es exactamente la misma
idea multipliquemos x al cuadrado x
cuadrada por x a la cuarta bueno tenemos
la misma base x podemos aplicar la
propiedad que acabamos de enunciar esto
va a ser igual a x elevado a la 24 x a
la sexta y si no me crees
tenemos x al cuadrado que equivale a
multiplicar x por si mismo dos veces que
multiplica a x a la cuarta y x a la
cuarta es multiplicar x por sí mismo 4
veces es decir es x x x x x x x cuantas
veces estamos multiplicando x por si
mismo bien 123456 estamos multiplicando
x por sí mismo 6 veces lo que equivale a
x elevado a la sexta hagamos otro de
estos entre más ejemplos veas yo creo
que es mucho mejor hagamos uno con la
otra propiedad así mezclamos problemas y
completamos las propiedades supongamos
que tenemos
al cubo y eso elevado a la cuarta te voy
a mostrar primero la propiedad y después
la ilustraremos cuando tienes algo
elevado a un exponente y a la vez eso
elevado otro exponente los exponentes se
multiplican así es que esto es a la 3
por 4 lo cual es igual a ha elevado a la
potencia 12 y porque esto hace sentido
bueno al cubo elevado a la cuarta quiere
decir al cubo multiplicado por si mismo
cuatro veces es decir a kubica por a
kubica por a kubica por a kubica estamos
elevando al cubo cuatro veces es decir
aa la 3 por 4 por lo cual esto es igual
a la tres más tres más tres más tres lo
cual es lo mismo que a a la tres por
cuatro lo cual es ha elevado a la
potencia 12 bien revisemos ahora las
propiedades que hemos aprendido en este
vídeo además de recordar el concepto de
exponente si tenemos x elevado a la x x
elevado a la vez esto es igual a x
elevado a la más b eso lo vimos aquí
arriba cuando hicimos x al cuadrado por
x a la cuarta es x a la 24 que es x
elevado a la sexta potencia también
vimos que sí tengo x porque elevado a la
potencia esto es igual a x elevado a la
x y elevado al a eso lo vimos acá arriba
casi al principio del vídeo cuando
hicimos 3x elevado al cubo lo cual
resultó en 3 al cubo por x al cubo es lo
que se está estableciendo en esta
propiedad 3x elevado al cubo es lo mismo
que 3 al cubo por x al cubo y la última
propiedad con la que nos topamos
si yo tengo x elevado a la que a la vez
está elevado a la b esto es igual a x
elevado a la a por b eso lo vimos aquí
donde teníamos al cubo elevado a la
cuarta lo cual es igual a elevado a la 3
por 4 lo cual es igual a elevado a la
potencia 12 ahora usemos estas
propiedades para hacer algunos de los
que podíamos designar como problemas más
complejos supongamos que tenemos que se
yo
déjame hacer algo así como ok supongamos
que tenemos 2 x de cuadrada por menos x
cuadrada y todo eso elevado al cuadrado
y por 3x cuadrada y cuadrada y queremos
simplificar esto empecemos por elevar
este término al cuadrado esto lo podemos
ver como menos 1 por x cuadrada porque
elevado al cuadrado así es que si
elevamos todo esto al cuadrado
esto es lo mismo que elevará al cuadrado
cada uno de estos factores así es que
esta parte de aquí la podemos describir
como menos 1 elevado al cuadrado por x
cuadrada elevado al cuadrado porque
elevado al cuadrado y esto se simplifica
como menos 1 al cuadrado es 1 x cuadrada
al cuadrado recuerda que puedes
multiplicar los exponentes así es que es
x a la cuarta por ie cuadrada y eso es a
lo que simplifica este término de
enmedio que tenemos aquí veamos si
podemos combinarlo con los otros
términos que tenemos el primer término
es 2x cuadrada y el último término es 3x
cuadrada ye cuadrada y ahora vamos a
realizar los productos que están
indicados y acuérdate que hemos
aprendido en la multiplicación que no
importa el orden el que hagamos las
multiplicaciones el orden de los
factores no altera el producto así es
que vamos a reescribir esto de tal
manera que sea fácil hacer las
multiplicaciones lo más simple es
empezar con los coeficientes 2 y 3
entonces tenemos 2
por tres vayamos ahora con los términos
en x los voy a hacer con otro color los
voy a hacer con este color x que tenemos
aquí lo aquí tenemos x a la cuarta y
finalmente tenemos x cuadrada por x
cuadrada vayamos ahora a los términos en
que tenemos ya cuadrada x nuevamente de
cuadrada y x nuevamente y encuadrada por
de cuadrada y esto a que es igual bien 2
x 3 es igual a 6 luego tenemos x por x a
la cuarta por x cuadrada esta x la
podemos ver como x a la 1
recordemos que algo elevado a la 1 es
ese mismo algo así por ejemplo si
tenemos 2 a la 1 es igual a 2 y 3 a la 1
es igual a 3 cualquier número elevado a
la 1 es el mismo número así es que
tenemos aquí esto va a ser igual a
tenemos la misma base x así es que
podemos sumar los exponentes esto va a
ser x a la uno más cuatro más dos
en el siguiente paso haré esta suma y
finalmente para las yes esto va a ser
igual
allí elevado a la potencia 2 más 2 más 2
y esto que nos da esto nos da 6 por
equis elevado a la séptima potencia por
ie elevado a la sexta potencia bien para
terminar este vídeo quiero platicar
contigo algo que quizás ya sabes y que
es muy interesante que pasa cuando
elevas algo a la potencia cero
si tenemos siete a la cero a que es
igual esto es muy poco intuitivo pero 7
a la 0 es igual a 1 lo mismo que si
tenemos 1 a la 0 es igual a 1
cualquier cosa elevada a la cero va a
ser igual a 1 cualquier número distinto
a la cero elevado a la cero va a ser
igual a 1 y para que tengas un poco la
intuición de por qué esto es así
veámoslo de la siguiente manera 3 a la
primera potencia
hagámoslo así aquí vamos a poner las
potencias 1 2 3
y luego a ser tan solo para el número
tres entonces que tenemos tres a la
primera potencia es 3 3 al cuadrado es 9
y 3 al cubo es 27 y estamos tratando de
encontrar cuánto estrés elevado a la
potencia cero piénsalo de la siguiente
manera cada vez que disminuye es el
exponente en uno estás dividiendo entre
tres para ir de 27 a nueve divides entre
3 para ir de 9 a 3 dividido entre 3
así es que quizás para ir del exponente
1 al exponente 0 habría que dividir
entre 3 y es por eso que cualquier cosa
elevado a la potencia cero en este caso
3 elevado a la potencia cero es 1 nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo